6 15 on your Thursday morning get ready
for a really really big teeny tiny art
show it's called The International
Market of miniature Artisans and our
Lauren Negrete is at the Gold Coast with
a big look at the small stuff hey Lauren
hey Nate yeah Market indeed I feel like
I'm going shopping right now there's my
vegetables in the bin here the basket
it's all courtesy of Pat Richmond here
with twin heart Miniatures now Pat you
have a great story for how this all got
started
yes uh I started like 20 years ago as a
business but I've Been Loved miniature
since I'm five years old and when my
daughter born we working on the
dollhouse and I'm making this for her
and people like it and I start the
business
perfect and also I want to make it to
Oriental miniature food and to show my
culture I love that and speaking on that
you have you have some issues here
um you have you said this is a pad thai
right there and how much does that cost
when people can buy on Saturday Sunday
they're all nine dollar is come with
utensil black or white and fortune
cookie you gotta have the fortune cookie
now this there's so much detail in here
even your vegetables you're going to cut
this cabbage for me here yes
beautiful here that Crunch and you made
those leaves one by one yes yes and you
can chop more to make coleslaw too that
is incredible you're gonna be able to
see stuff like this again here it's
interesting only during the week but
come Saturday Sunday come on down 12
bucks for adults to get in six four kids
eight and older and there's even a
children's Workshop come Saturday too
we've got more details for you on our
website at 8newsnow.com for now live in
Las Vegas with some pretty great food
here uh we're coming up here learn to go
to 8 news now I can't get over that I
mean the fact that it
is actually wow well I I can just say
that that's coleslaw for anybody on a
diet because it's not a very big survey
but it sure is beautiful to look on
incredible thank you Lauren appreciate
that do you get teeny tiny Chopsticks to
go with that or what